hey Keith what's up man today's your
lucky day
I sent out your entire schedule and
we're gonna good adventure you don't
have the authority no I did don't worry
bring your bread let's go best friends
forever
well that's France nothing let's go okay
so what are we doing we are on our way
right now to eat three different sushi
restaurants not the restaurant something
I didn't think you meant but we're gonna
go to the restaurant gonna go to three
of the best sushi restaurant it's a read
drastically different price point and
compare which one is the best experience
probably the really expensive one it's
gonna be about you have to way value pay
as well as atmos - it's the whole
experience each roll at this first spot
is screwed on is it good
yes it's unbelievable we've been there
no oh yeah but I've heard a lot of good
things up
hey guys a crayon welcome to sushi stop
I want to go back to meet chef yes my
dad wakes up every morning at 4 a.m. to
go to the fish market in downtown LA he
hand picks all of our fresh fish and
vegetables and he drops it off at every
rep he drops it off yeah he doesn't know
I'm like low-end person do it that's how
we keep our prices low while at the same
time keeping the quality of the fish you
guys are going to be trying out the
bluefin tuna sushi you can just see how
tender it is from like how it's pulling
away from the fat already that's France
oh whoa whoa wrap $4 that is incredible
what constitutes quality is fresh fish
isn't going to have a fishy or a smelly
odor when you eat the sushi it's gonna
be firm enough to hold its shape but
when you take your first bite it's just
gonna melt in your mouth now you guys
are gonna have the spicy scallop roll
right walk out I don't think I have the
scallop but now cook I imagine that
that's exactly how it is the texture is
really great and how much is this this
is 295
this is do 90 this is the last dish so
this is a seasonal special that were low
in our restaurant right now a Spanish
mackerel from Japan I don't want to say
the most beautiful thing I've ever seen
because my girlfriend's datapool looking
back at you so we might be the most
beautiful thing it
ever seen man whoa that's great right I
think we're done here I think we had a
really great experience he's bringing
more more food thank you very much oh so
I want to show you guys this plate
before we make it into sushi realize
wheat shrimps we cut this and we make
the tail art into sushi you're a swamp
pretty perfect and he's watching me eat
his but I've never had this good of food
for that little the price so whoa God
Steve don't you back that's what the
most dangerous sushi is is it the
pufferfish it's a bummer Vic I knew it I
watched the Simpson now that we had
really acclaimed but cheap sushi yeah
what is really a claim good mid-tier
sushi I'm hoping this sushi is better
that's gonna have to do a good job nice
to meet you how long have you been
master sushi chef I've just felt like a
subpoena
I guess started 16 yeah how do you guys
turn the price on your vision people
think about all the fish gonna be fish
it's not really nice people except
urbanizing called high gamma then you
use the archive into the exact vinegar
great well I'd love to see those two
hands at work show us what you got the
presentation element of this is out of
control it makes me really really want
to eat this sushi king that I got it's
like pumpkin oh yeah tongue is just
living in a sexy salt bath right now I
honestly don't feel worthy to eat a dish
like this I do
just good aren't worthy of good things
in life all I wanted you want to start
with the one that was on fire who knows
500c I love that there's an order to
madness its act 1 act 2 and 3 such a
really good blend of flavors
this little sneak of wasabi in there
everybody is just such a like a little
ride and it comes out of nowhere - it's
like you're eating out of nowhere
I'm like visually what I've been waiting
for this whole time
is that rock shell crab roll we call the
pig on crap nothing kills outside food
that's not tradition although that
doesn't but it's yours but that sounds
good this is America right here oh it
smells so good pickle in there Cajun
spice that's like a drug man all the
details put together yeah that makes
this elevated take your girl out take
your toy out have some pains please your
boy Steven Lee oh yes let's get out of
here I'm so full I'm tired of headache
Steven Keith I feel great there's you
back
guess what sushi chefs do the octopus
who make it have a softer texture Oh
emirate they give it a full-body massage
famous on Schism yeah a little ooh this
place all right in the third place we
are gonna get something hot Oh Mikasa
I can't have my mind blown anymore
yes PTSD worked for me for almost 20
years she's been very well so great I'll
a make sushi I just thought my friend
Keith has never had omakase before
omakase being you trust me how I can
amaze the first bite second bite
goodbye I feel it yeah I'm so excited to
try it I'm ready to experience what
you're gonna make for us
[Music]
[Applause]
you
pencil above allwhy tuna the closest to
a mouth chasm i never achieve baby tuna
from Baja California I don't know what
it is about young animals they taste so
good
bluefin tuna from Spain almost
indescribable like I am at a point where
I have tears welling up in my eyes about
how good that bite was yeah it'll tail
on the Sun here we go it's very strong
yeah what do you mean but I don't know
halibut and the Japanese not from Japan
big muscley oyster from Washington get
up and the shiitake mushroom from Santa
Barbara Ann bokram comedic monkfish
liver
Ujala butter fish here G compatible quad
this is a samway egg from Canada that
was the best part I've had all day now
you come to the end of the course most
sales in my lesson is a blue crab roe so
I make it look we give you the hand roll
because you have to eat right away
Oh
[Music]
as we were driving here people's like I
don't know if there's anything that
could happen where I'd be like that be
levels above yeah what we just suggest
yes that I needed to be treated like a
princess
and you did it so who wins the will to
win you know what I I'm gonna choose
sushi stop the reason being is I will
see myself eating there a lot the foodie
and me is screaming and saying something
I mean I just never had experience like
that I do need to put a special shout
out for that Asian crab roll oh maybe
that was amazing you know what I gotta
say taking me to that last place you got
to be one of my best friends hey alright
just don't ever laugh like that again I
could bring my girl I could bring a date
here not throw them the bill and
everything erections your girlfriend to
a date catch yourself